Цей поверх у слідчому ізоляторі виділений для військовополонених росіян.
Їх тримають окремо від інших ув'язнених - заради безпеки самих полонених. З цієї ж причини DW не можна називати, де саме розташований ізолятор.
У цій камері семеро людей різного віку. Усі мали контракт зі збройними силами РФ.
Артем - рядовий солдат танкових військ. Розповідає, що приєднався до так званої спецоперації, бо вірив у її "ідею".
Просто почалася розсилка в інтернеті у нас в Росії: "Потрібні на роботу люди в місто Донецьк".
Я через соцмережі зв'язався з одним, мені сказали 30 березня прибути на КПП Мар'ївка, це в Ростовській області.
Я туди прибув, і там уже контракт на мене чекав - механіком-водієм Т-72, тобто на танк. Там я в Донецьку швиденько пройшов навчання за два-три дні.
З одного боку багато там політики, так надивився. У нас, знаєте, по телевізору дуже красиво розповідають,
нібито ми за добру справу йдемо воювати, а насправді це зовсім не так. Тільки тут очі відкрилися.
Артем у складі 100-ої бригади так званої "ДНР" поїхав воювати у Запорізьку область. Його танк підбили.
Я навіть у полон до "Азова" потрапив. І не бачив ніяких фашистів. Надали першу допомогу, у мене були сильні опіки. На обличчі ще лишилися.
Годували, цигарки давали. Ніхто нічого… Навпаки, так само питали: "Ну що, бачиш ти тут десь фашистів?".
Гірке розчарування просто у своїй владі, в народі, який її підтримує.
Інший полонений - Роман із міста Виборг Ленінградської області. Розповідає, що їхав в Україну нібито роздавати гуманітарну допомогу.
Потрапив у полон на Харківщині.
Чесно кажучи, трохи обманули. Спершу обіцяли, що ми будемо займатися гуманітаркою.
Мене одразу кинули в темну на передову ось до хлопців, шість днів під обстрілами, на сьомий день усіх підняли і їдемо.
Був поранений під час бою, свої кинули, і на наступний день взяли в полон військовослужбовці Збройних сил України.
Надали невідкладну допомогу, доставили.
Уже в місці утримання полонених у Романа дістали осколки з ніг і рук. Умовами утримання чоловік задоволений.
Щодня заходять, питають, чи треба щось -  без питань. Якщо є можливість, нам це надають. Харчування збалансоване.
Здебільшого каші, м'ясо. Сьогодні була кукурудзяна каша з м'ясом.
У полонених столові прибори металеві. Хоча у звичайних в'язнів пластикові.
Співробітники СІЗО не на камеру пояснюють: полонені - неагресивні, їм нікуди тікати, вони просто чекають обміну.
Життя в ізоляторі протікає за розпорядком. Є прогулянки, миття в лазні, триразове харчування.
Хлопці, обід!
Страви роздають звичайні українські ув'язнені під наглядом охоронців. Це їхня робота.
У ще одній камері троє молодих хлопців. Кажуть, особистий час проводять за читанням книжок,
які їм дісталися від тюремного бібліотекаря: Купрін, Тургєнєв, англійські детективи.
Дмитру 20 років, він - контрактник. Каже, не усвідомлював, як 24 лютого з Бєлгородської області потрапив в Україну.
У тому то й справа, що нам не казали, куди ми їдемо. Усі вже дізналися про територію України, коли побачили номерні знаки, прапори.
Спитав у командира: що ми тут робимо? Отримав таку відповідь: "Не став зайвих запитань, їдь прямо". Усе.
Дмитро стверджує, що їхній підрозділ не заїжджав у села й міста, не перетинався з цивільним населенням.
27 лютого під Прилуками танк, у якому їхав Дмитро, розбили. Він з товаришем склав зброю і здався.
З армією точно покінчено. Сім'ю, мабуть, буду створювати, не знаю. Там видно буде, що далі думати. Треба додому повернутися.
Полонений Олег родом з республіки Карелія. Він потрапив у полон у селі Веселе на Харківщині.
Його взвод відступав. Кілька років тому Олега звільнили зі служби за контрактом, але в березні зателефонували з воєнкомату
і запропонували взяти участь у так званій "спецоперації".
Операція уже йшла, інформацію я дивився в новинах, що говорили там. Насправді, коли я потрапив сюди - уже не сходиться.
Я зрозумів, що там усе інакше описують: що тут націоналісти, що тут ЗСУ самі по своїх містах стріляють.
Олег каже, що йому обіцяли два тижні підготовки і службу в тилу. Але через три дні після підписання контракту він уже йшов маршем на Харків.
Екіпаж МТ-ЛБ у нас був, я командир відділення. Там кулеметник - людина з кулеметом ніколи не вправлялася - ти будеш кулеметником,
ти - гранатометником, РПГ дали йому. Люди навіть не вміли користуватися цією зброєю правильно.
Військовий стверджує, що після тижня боїв на "передку" його взвод захотів повернутися в Росію, але командування не дало дозволу.
Подивилися на все, що тут відбувається, - націоналістів тут я не побачив жодного.
Люди в селах, коли ми заходили в села, відверто нам кажуть: "Ідіть звідси, вам нема що тут робити".
Ось такий тиск. Наче ти їм і гуманітарку завозиш. Вони сказали: "Поки ви тут, село під контролем, ми з вами. Але ви підете, ЗСУ прийдуть. Ми жити хочемо".
Але деякі, пів села нам кажуть: "Їдьте додому, навіщо ви сюди приїхали".
Спершу очікували, що люди тут у злиднях. Допомагати будемо, тут будуть раді нам. А виявилося все по-іншому.
Це психологічно так… Ми зрозуміли, що ми тут непотрібні, що нас надурили.
Усі полонені, з якими поспілкувалася DW, запевняють, що не обстрілювали мирні села й міста, не цілилися в мирних мешканців.
Доказів скоєння ними воєнних злочинів слідчі не виявили. Полонених перевіряли на детекторі брехні.
Співробітники СІЗО не на камеру розповідають історію полоненого Вадима Шишимаріна - його теж тримали в цьому ізоляторі.
Лише на детекторі брехні росіянин зізнався, що стріляв у мирного жителя Сумщини і вбив його. Полоненого засудили до довічного ув'язнення.
У розмові з DW жоден полонений не поскаржився на погані умови утримання чи негуманне ставлення.
За даними мін'юсту, лише на харчування, одяг, засоби гігієни і комунальні платежі для одного полоненого потрібно 3000 гривень на місяць.
Також є витрати на медичне обладнання, ліки, зарплату персоналу.
За словами полонених, їх відвідують співробітники ООН і Червоного Хреста. Вони спілкуються з росіянами, записують їхні дані та історії.
Голова місії ООН з прав людини в Україні Матільда Богнер підтверджує, що в знятому СІЗО умови утримання задовільні.
І все ж стверджує, що її команда фіксує порушення у ставленні до полонених і з боку України, і з боку Росії.
На жаль, у нас є інформація, що безпосередньо після взяття в полон для них є ризик неналежного ставлення і катувань, їх можуть бити.
Ми знаємо про щонайменше один випадок катувань російських полонених електричним струмом і застосування інших методів, зокрема, позбавлення сну.
Коли їх переводять до СІЗО, за нашою інформацією, до полонених уже ставляться належним чином.
Ми також зібрали інформацію з різних джерел і маємо занепокоєння з приводу ставлення до українських полонених.
Одразу після взяття в полон їх також можуть бити й катувати.
Але й після переведення їх до місць утримання вони так само можуть піддаватися катуванням.
Наскільки ми розуміємо, умови можуть бути поганими - нестача їжі, антисанітарія, грубе ставлення з боку тюремних наглядачів.
Також в ООН занепокоєні наразі не підтвердженою інформацією, що українських полонених
тримають в тюрмі "Ізоляція" в Донецьку і схожих установах. Щодо України - у представництві вітають початок
розслідувань щодо неналежного ставлення до полонених з боку військових.
Також наголошують, що полонених варто утримувати в окремих таборах.
Загалом ООН закликає обидві сторони стримувати емоції, коли йдеться про військовополонених.